this video was supported in part by our
friends at curiosity stream what if
viewers get 30 days completely free when
they click on the link in the
description below and use the promo code
what if it's as strong as battery acid
and it can melt steel but it lives
inside of us and helps digest our food
this is stomach acid is stomach acid
dangerous if it's this powerful why
doesn't it hurt us and what would happen
if we jumped into a pool full of the
stuff this is what if and here's what
would happen if we jumped into a pool
full of stomach acid that's right
stomach acid is compared to battery acid
in terms of the damage it can do it can
range from a 1 to a 3 on the pH scale
meaning it's extremely acidic
that's because stomach acids main
component is hydrochloric acid which is
a highly corrosive substance the reason
it can live inside us is due to a
special mucous membrane that lines our
stomachs but what would happen if we
covered all our skin with it now
Before we jump into a pool full of
stomach acid first thing we need to do
is figure out how we're going to be able
to fill up an entire pool with stomach
acid let's assume that we're swimming in
an average 6 by 6 meter pool that can
hold 55,000 litres of liquid a stomach
can produce at most one and a half
litres of stomach acid a day so to fill
up an entire pool we need the stomach's
of over 50,000 people ok so we found
50,000 volunteers who were able to help
us fill up the pool before you even jump
into it you're going to notice the awful
smell
whenever there's excess acid in your
digestive tract it can cause your breath
to stink so multiply that by 50,000 and
you'd get an idea of how awful the pool
would smell and you'd be surrounded by
horrible bad breath odor and that's even
before you jump in
as soon as you take the plunge you'll
feel stinging in your eyes and your
nostrils to get a sense of what this
might feel like have you ever had lemon
juice squirted in your eye it would be
similar to that as lemon juice and
stomach acid have a similar pH level but
if you remember to bring your goggles
and your nose plugs hopefully you'll be
able to avoid this part what's much less
avoidable is the stomach acid making
contact with your skin when it does
it'll cause some mild irritation right
away
luckily the epidermis layer of your skin
should be able to protect you before it
starts to hurt too badly if you jump
into the pool and hop right back out
even with your skin all covered in
stomach acid
you'd be relatively okay apart from the
mild irritation as long as you wash the
acid off with soap and water and towel
off you'll be totally fine but what if
we stayed in the stomach acid for much
longer if you didn't get out right away
the acid would slowly eat your skin this
would eventually leave you covered in
second and third degree burns if you
didn't manage to cover your eyes during
the swim you slowly lose your vision and
end up blind and your nose it would
dissolve from the inside if the acid
touched it long enough oh and if you
accidentally swallow some of it you'll
inevitably vomit it back up uh what do
you have for lunch given the dangers
here it's probably best you don't try it
you'd be best to leave stomach acid
where it belongs and that's inside of us
digesting our food but what if we went
inside a stomach more specifically a
whale stomach
well that's a story for another what if
thanks again to our friends at curiosity
stream for lending their support to this
video
curiosity stream is the subscription
streaming service with thousands of
award-winning documentaries and
nonfiction titles for you to choose from
you can get unlimited access to
curiosity stream starting at just $2.99
a month or just $19.99 a year and what
if viewers get the first 30 days
completely free all you have to do is
sign up at curiosity stream comm slash
what if and use the promo code what if
during the signup process
[Music]